[Music]
this transparent strip is made of one of
the strongest materials on earth
and now we're going to inject this into
your body
could it make your cells regenerate
faster
would this mineral ever leave your
system
and is it in you already
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were injected with
graphene
humans have been using graphite to draw
since the stone age and now we mine it
to keep our batteries charged and
machines lubed
but graphene
well that's something new
this material first seen in 2004
is only one atom thick
found after peeling off transparent tape
from graphite the mineral stuck to the
tape was named graphene
and it might be the first
two-dimensional substance ever
discovered
but don't be fooled by its size
graphene is 100 times stronger than
steel and powerful enough to repel most
gases and liquids
discovering it has revolutionized
battery and information technology but
if graphene atoms enter your bloodstream
what would happen to your cells
you can create graphene oxide by
oxidizing graphite
and this nanoparticle graphene oxide can
be used in medical treatments since it
breaks down in water fast
drugs injected into your system could be
delivered to their destinations faster
thanks to this cheap and readily
available substance
studies in lab rats have shown that
graphene caused tumors to shrink
other tests showed that graphene might
even make your bones regenerate quicker
but all this comes at a cost
we'll come back to that
some false reports online state that
some covet 19 vaccines are 99
graphene oxide
these injections contain graphene
again this rumor is false but if that
much graphene oxide entered your
bloodstream
the consequences might be dire remember
our knowledge of graphene is limited
so what do we know
well studies in mice show that graphene
can build up inside the lungs
graphene sheets only nanometers thick
would grow and collect causing fluids to
build up inside your lungs
you could drown on the inside without
even touching a drop of water
but what would graphene do to your brain
well if you were injected with graphene
a small amount could cross the dreaded
blood brain barrier
this roadblock in your nervous system
stops bacteria and viruses from getting
into your brain
now if graphene enters your brain
most of the mineral would dissolve over
the next two days but
you're not in the clear yet
the jagged graphene nanoparticles could
pierce your blood cells and completely
disrupt their function
and if it damages your kidney cells
proteins could leak into your urine
this would make your eyes and ankles
swell
this condition known as nephrotic
syndrome would also kill your appetite
well you might have lost that already
while graphene has quickly
revolutionized the tech and medical
industries
we still don't know what this mineral
can do to us in the long run
is it a miracle of nature or
is it a killer in disguise
i mean it wouldn't be the first time we
tried putting something potentially
dangerous in our bodies in the name of
science
like
what if you drank snake venom
well sharpen your fangs because that's a
story
for another
what if
you